misrata une ville libyenne située à
moins de 400 kilomètres des côtes
italiennes
depuis plusieurs années elle voit
affluer des centaines de réfugiés venus
d'égypte de syrie et d'afrique
subsaharienne
bonjour vous allez bien où se trouve le
centre de rétention des clandestins au
rond-point à droite après le deuxième
immeuble merci
ce soir là j'accompagne mouftah il est
officier de police il m'emmène visité un
centre de rétention de clandestins c'est
cette simple maison de deux étages
derrière cette grille plusieurs dizaines
d'hommes s'entassent certains sont
encore des adolescents
la plupart viennent d'erythrée ou de
syrie comme ce jeune homme dis moi tu
voulais aller où toi en europe en italie
tu voulais te rendre en italie
et comment tu arrivé là on était quinze
ont voulu rejoindre l'europe on est
passé par le soudan de notre pays lire
la guerre est ici aussi on voudrait
juste partir pour vivre en paix en
europe
c'est quoi ton métier je suis diplômée
en droit mais je travaille comme
électricien pourquoi tu n'es pas rentrer
légalement pour travailler ici mais on
nous donne pas de visas
ils sont emprisonnés ici depuis dix
jours et n'ont aucune idée du sort que
les autorités de misrata leur réserve
tu sais que tu vas être pris tu sais qui
va être vendu
tu sais qu'ils peuvent arracher à rein
ou un oeil
les passeurs qui profitent de la guerre
sont partout ils sont libyens ou
tchadien
à l'eau j'en ai 50 ok tu peux me les
envoyer au moment de la traversée
avis ne signifie rien pour eux ils
prennent t 1000 $ et basse là tu es
juste une marchandise allez bonne nuit
monsieur c'est quoi notre avenir ici mon
avenir mais je ne connais même pas le
mien
inquiète tu vas sortir si dieu le veut
et tu auras ton visa et tu auras du
travail
théoriquement ces sommes devraient être
expulsés vers leur pays d'origine
mais en sortant du centre mouffetard vam
avouer que cette règle un peu de chance
de s'appliquer on ne va pas les expulser
ce sont nos frères dans l'islam et en
plus ils sont arabes on prend soin d'eux
où veux tu qu'ils aillent et comment les
garder ici mais comment les renvoyer
c'est un vrai problème les renvoyer en
syrie dans un pays en guerre et l'italie
nous montre du doigt elle dit que nous
facilitons l'immigration clandestine
mais que veulent absolument partir en
europe il préfère la prison en europe
que la liberté en afrique
débordées par l'afflux des réfugiés la
libye n'a pas les moyens de les retenir
indéfiniment
ni de les renvoyer tous dans leur pays
d'origine ce qu'elle parvienne à
raccompagner à la frontière reviennent
pour la plupart jouer leur destin sur
des bateaux de fortune
[Musique]